so this next story i know it's going to
be hard for a lot of people to see
beyond the physical appearance of the
individuals that we're talking about
there are twin anti-vaccine brothers the
bogdanov twins
who were actually of memetic fame they
were like crypto meme
figures in in cryptocurrency related
memes
both of these brothers whose physical
appearance is bizarre and we'll talk
about that in a moment they both died of
covet unvaccinated within days of each
other now if you're not familiar with
these individuals these are gritshka
and igor baghdanov
they
were known
for a couple of different things to some
they were known for their their uh
placement they figured prominently in
cryptocurrency related memes to others
they were known as having what appears
to be bizarre plastic surgery
if you look at pictures of these
individuals decades ago they look
completely different they as far as i
know denied having plastic surgery as
you can see
you know they have these cheekbones
that are so bulbous that according to an
australian newspaper they quote threaten
their own vision
um
extremely controversial and and
strange-looking individuals
they obtained doctorates by writing what
are considered allegedly meaningless
physics papers
they claim to be descendants of nobility
etc etc they're both dead of covet
they're both dead of covet the daily
beast writes their voyage through the
stars ended in a parisian hospital
where both grichka and igor bogdanov had
been admitted on the same day after
contracting kovid grichka the younger
twin died in icu on december 28th igor
followed him on monday both were 72
years old a source close to the brothers
told the french media outlet le monde
that neither had been vaccinated against
the virus
it is you know you can read about these
individuals if it's interesting to you
but it is another one of these stories
both unvaccinated
both dead of covid and i don't you know
but particularly in this case because of
their appearance and the entire sort of
cult of personality around them
a lot of people are just laughing at
this
i i really don't find it funny it's just
sad it's sad and the vaccine doesn't
protect anyone 100 percent but colin
powell
very immunocompromised but had the full
regimen of vaccines died from covert or
covert complications it it doesn't
protect everyone
but don't you want a better shot don't
you want a better shot if the suit of
armor is available and you're gonna walk
through a forest where arrows are going
to be fired
you might never confront an arrow you
they might go whizzing next to you they
might never actually hit you but
wouldn't you rather the suit of armor if
there are going to be arrows flying
that's my view
and many of you know that already
uh but the bogdanov twins the crypto
meme twins both dead of covid within
days of each other and in the in the
next segment i'm going to tell you about
my
confrontation with covet a lot of people
i teased this like 10 days ago and
people have been writing saying david
what what's the deal with that
i wanted to wait to have what was
hopefully the full story i believe i
have it now and i'm going to be talking
about that after the break make sure
you're following me on instagram
david.pacman you can also follow the
show
on facebook facebook.comdavidpakmanshow
we'll take a break we will be right back